yeah
and you've been traveling around so well
my task is to find a new pack the
migration and asylum and that's why I'm
reaching out to all the Member States to
have a dialogue and me and Matias who
had a very good dialogue today and I
think that we understand each other's
positions and I think that there is a
good sign of many member states
including Denmark that are ready to take
steps forward for a pragmatic solution
the Danish idea is to create camps in
northern Africa where you place the
asylum seekers so they don't come into
Europe even if they apply for asylum
what do you think about that idea I
don't think it's a realistic idea I
think we need to come forward now we
need to be we need to manage migration
we be need to be in control of migration
and that's why and it's urgent
we need a new pack that can be accepted
by all the Member States and that can
take steps forward and I think that's
why I don't think it's realistic to find
with these kind of proposals today
megistus fire ET de leur the new father
how come you say anti-stall furthermore
you know learning some mailing to me
some lapis told ya for the far a mic on
your suffers but then choose good i
gaining and they here can see those who
fought any day you have offensively
R'lyeh he Norfolk's amis Iowa hooding as
the jacket structure is now I'm done I'm
a big units imperious excluding the
active happening and why hold it me
limit them to skip emails minister
no may Commission a five person oh yeah
Emily posted all of us kill or at the
therefore held in Labine decline
Aleutian named Annette up often a con
leg minute hour at VA constancy it's a
clear it a assume sustainment Newburn
availa some say car Sega who do offer
some second solemn occasion say open
awesome deal buddy man's got a new spoke
with the whole so yeah see at Emmaus I'm
a glass of health food descriptive I
didn't write T of acne Oh Giggy in email
of it cyclamen main area MIDI place the
means can give after two tails
man if this me know who knows there
Kennedy Kennedy inspiration then plainly
huh you carry world has bad very bad
warning not to mr. Pope Jamieson say
that max what the funnel and swung it at
E felony where the Peter on the TV
schedule a king's piston you can shear
stress the Petersons a offense
frightening organization
eager perfume many corner Democrats a
massive looting our own be encamping
whom a meteor storm act at is Caviar's
where miss kield for when you proof of
his Caruso at the new bonuses thing were
held in the tender service cruciate I'm
ecstatic at the hopefully of obvious no
problem a mess in Tokyo
yeah so Jade who halva the Indian who
managed is commenced Kahala estoppel are
therefore bill intense kept again
thought said fulfil the modem and fourth
leadership sighs panting woman fight
over the idea luma clear lens like
hearing a via again Minami idiot
d'Italia me at all so yeah I only can
say dachshund is still the you're
handsome the Danish plane you think is
unrealistic but what are your plan to
change the system that you all agree on
doesn't work as it should
my plan is to be very pragmatic and to
lesson to all the member states the
previous Commission are presented
proposals created in Brussels that has
not been able to be adopted by the
council member states have blocked this
so my approach is to be realistic to
listen to member states to find a
compromise that can be accepted by all
the member states and I think that's why
I'm going to have these dialogues that I
have today and it holds with all member
states and of course I can't answer
before I had all this die
but I guess a lot of protecting our
external border will be a very important
part being more efficient on returns
will be a very important part and to
find our way of mandatory solidary
mechanism that could be accepted by all
Member States will also be important so
that we can help those countries of
first entry in a meaningful way as a
Danish Minister convinced you just a
little bit in finding a little more
realistic his plans after this meeting I
don't think that there's a lot of legal
and practical question marks of having
these kind of centers outside the
European Union so I think this is not
what we should focus on right now what
we should focus on now is to find a new
pack that can fly that can be accepted
by all Member States that can protect
our borders that can show that we can
manage migration being controller
migration and make a distinction between
those that are eligible for
international protection and those that
are not and those should return and I
think this is absolutely doable and this
is what I focus on mr. Speicher do for
still then density like gearing as a ten
marks on Williams land to accept change
in new parks I'm eager to the a bridle
say Emily Sinclair willfully you meant
what mood sails into the foggy when main
admin figures no under agreement I'm
selling the previous excrete in
Reykjavik me sorry mister another house
with you for Denmark at the LAX and mr.
Percy us enjoy saline at be previous
it's good in Reykjavik so sturdily they
I heard concern a day they're stupid
fools poor at the hand mere strict a
concept Bachman distillery that's to the
focus per all these photos taken out the
hope of the screws put me on face good
answer
disturbing that's too good focus for a
second so Madame de vacas can commence a
over disturbing Susilo Nico he'll divine
salmon hardy-har UDI so Corbett Olli
divine a bet is discrete in Reykjavik me
DVB maka mmm it's a sake regard bear
Gabriel could fill co-pays nibble at
mine off madam would say 705 open
Manette tip Leah known for you pesky
Muslims when Ducati Matthias tell about
his family for the apace casuistry
medieval first I'd like a whole zoo
controller in 1904 the fruit makes every
day our policy tape or conflict on again
now that I have words of atonement
because more than four Komatsu do davis
cahit Makela fora at eco make a movie
you I'll tell you I mean lead for the
mekinese man in first you don't work or
some silly ha he saw given field yes I'm
plane made it no Afghanistan muskie
cheap and are you please clean it aa
Leone's announcing it as a previous
people Peggy Houston yeah
for us at eat it in Ella the eager in
India Paige Gosney Latin tense kappa
games [ __ ]
they below yet so fact is mr. skevur
very dismayed intense loosening Sophia's
not say loosening up get on
failed see over the handler plan Daniel
I'm a student fills up a ski cancer
I have habits are the first discreet
he's gay she chosen many new pace click
on select a phone sex at you first it
ELISA stay Livia being said they'd
failed squid take a big girl in the
divinity touka-sama buying the boss
co-pays government can we say I'm
getting sued Taylor also been a
faithless earpiece for dating snarling
after looking at a comma to all my
students read a commercial but they pass
like night bear had in reading rather
the ankle knee high socks Akuma sandy
say me if you do see them does care for
Taylor's it's a tad Mac this cake him
give him just developing a philosophy
way over there far dynamic for example
him bein such a fan hates all Sue's not
needing a sack became it's a seriously
threatening our policy secure Halen set
him in a degree no Fidel disused
flirting at our set psycho in a [ __ ]
consejo such is gonna be bad enough
Lea's SSI poem them describes courtesy
of over the entire fluid media office
girls of fatigue at the Louisville is
some of iron made any Lance became moon
for over someone may offend are the
eager Ahmedabad Minsky smugglin discover
console a lattice cake batter in a key
design a momentous movie
say that it was in sponsor secretary
contention that the Danish government
tries to run from its responsibility I
have no comment on that but I really
appreciate that the Danish government
now is restarting the resettlement
propogate program
I think resettlement is a very important
part of a way forward for the European
migration policies it sounds like even
agreeing upon a new system continue
services we don't have that time we
don't have that time at all it's urgent
really urgent we do have a timeline for
how long I have a timeline but I also
said I will have a dialogue with all
Member States so I think it's not wise
of me to set up a very sharp timeline
before I have listened to all the Member
States and have a dialogue with them yes
I hope to finish this before the end of
January thank you